Wow  what up dip shits drew here sharp  ah  so check this out here's a few reasons  why I love sharks so much one mt  to that big  3 when someone makes me pissed i watch  the shark attack video on YouTube and I  pretend that shark is attacking the  person that pissed me off  the shark has Heather in the grip of its  deadly jaws attacker attack Tiffany my  ex who broke my heart at the mall so  check this out here's a little secret  about drew boy hair I have a really tiny  penis but I still get all the honey's  because I tell them that a shark bit off  half of my dick  all right guys have a kick ass shark  week I'm gonna go surf in and see if a  shark can bite me right on the lips I  can get a piercing there  you